تقرير صادم للامم المتحده في التمييز بين
الجنسين العالم بيرجع للوراء وجديد اطفال
الغابه المعجزه قصه كلب حماهم هون عليهم
المحنه ولماذا يتم تحنيط قرش الغردقه
الاجابه في الحلقه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في تقرير صادر عن برنامج الامم المتحده
الانمائي امس فارض نفسه اليوم كعنواننا
الاول خاصه وانه بيناقش وحده من القضايا
اللي بنعتبرها من قضيان الاساسيه في
تفاعلكم حقيقه ان التقرير مخيب للاعمال
جدا التقرير بيناقش مؤشر التمييز بين
الجنسين في العالم ونتائجه بتقول ببساطه
انه التمييز بين الجنسين ما شاف اي تحسن
اطلاقا في اخر عشر سنوات يعني شيء فعليا
مخيب للامال فوق الوصف وطبعا هذه النتيجه
بتعيق تحقيق احد اهداف الامم المتحده
واللي هو تحقيق المساواه بين الجنسين
بحلول عشرين ثلاثين ما في امل يعني لكن
يبدو انه العالم طبعا بعيد سنين ضوئيه زي
ما قلنا عن هذا الهدف البحث شمل 80 دوله
ونتائجه مللت 33 صفحه وهذه ببساطه النتائج
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده كانت تحلم يختفي التمييز
بين الجنسين خلال سبع سنين والتقرير بيقول
محتاجين 300 سنه التقرير صادم حقيقه ولو
حنختصر ابرز ما فيه في التقرير بيقول انه
تسعه من بين كل عشره في العالم بيميزوا ضد
المراه وهنا بنتكلم على رجال ونساء يعني
تسعه رجال ونساء من بين كل عشره اشخاص في
العالم بميزوا ضد المراه التقرير بيقول
كمان انه نص سكان العالم شايفين الرجال
افضل في القياده السياسيه و43% شايفين
الرجال افضل في اداره الاعمال 46% كمان
شايفين انه الرجل لازم يكون له حقوق اكثر
من السيدات التقرير كمان قال انه زمان كان
دخل الشخص ومستويات تعليمي بيفرق في
النظره للتمييز بين الرجل والمراه لكن
الان المعادن يفرق يعني التحصيل العلمي
العالي او الدخل المرتفع مو بالضروره
معناه مو بالضروري معناه انه الشخص يكون
داعم للمساواه او عدم التمييز الامم
المتحده قالت كمان عكس ما كان متوقع حملات
عالميه مثل
اللي بتدافع عن المراه وبتنادي بحقوقها
ووقف الاعتداءات عليها ما اثرت في النظره
العامه للتمييز بين الجنسين ولا زالت
الاعراف والعادات اقوى من كل شيء في هذا
الخصوص نجي للكلام عن العنف وهنا كارثه
اكبر واكبر في الارقام لانه تقرير اليو ان
دي بي بيقول انه واحد من كل اربعه في
العالم شايفين انه عادي الرجل يضرب زوجته
او شريكته ولو حنتكلم عن الفجوه في الاجور
فمتوسط الفرق 39% يعني الرجال لما بيشتغل
شغلانه والست بتسوي نفس الشغلانه بالضبط
هو بياخد راتب اعلى منها ب 39% مع انه في
57 دوله من الثمانين الستات اكثر تحصيل في
الدرجات العلميه ومع انها كمان خلينا نذكر
بتقضي سته اضعاف الرجل في اداء مهام
الرعايه والمنزل الى جانب وظيفتهم او
عملهم طيب من عمان بيت انضم الينا دكتوره
عصمت حوسو رئيسه مركز الجندر للاستشارات
الاجتماعيه يعني دكتوره عصمت هذا واقع نحن
كلنا عايشينه يعني خلينا نكون صريحين مع
بعض بس لما ينحط في تقرير امامنا ونشوف
الارقام كذا كلها مع بعض ونشوف انه يعني
النفق مظلم خلينا نقول صراحه حنشعر
بالاكتئاب خصوصا لما نلاقي انه يعني حتى
النساء بطالعوا او عندهم تمييز ضد المراه
نفس الرجل كيف نقدر نفسر هذا الشيء
اه يعطيك العافيه ساره دايما مواضيعك مهمه
انا بالنسبه الي التقرير مش صادم كوحده
مختصه بعمل بالمجال اطلاقا ما كانت
النتائج صادمه كثير في اسباب رح اسلط
الضوء على اهمها اذا بتاملوا كل المؤسسات
الدوليه والامم المتحده العاملين بهذا
المجال يعملوا تغيير حتى لو بعد كمان
عشرين ثلاثين سنه وبالاضافه للي راح ما
راح يصير تغيير ليش اولا هم بحكوا بلغه
النوع الاجتماعي اللي هو الجندر
والنوع الاجتماعي يعنى في الجنسين يعني هو
بحكي عن المراه والرجل ادوارهم وبيركزوا
على المراه اكثر
فهذا الحكي مؤذي لانه لما يحكم بلغه
احاديه بس على المراه عامل الموضوع رد فعل
عكسي عند اغلب المجتمعات سواء الغربيه او
دول العالم الثالث والعربيه رد فعل عكسي
وكانه صار الموضوع هجوم شخصي على الرجل
لما نتعامل كده لانه هي المراه اللي
بتعاني من المشكله نعم المراه تعاني اكثر
لكن منقدرش نعمم وعلى فكره انا مبسوطه انه
اعتبروا الدراسه عالميه وعلى 85% من سكان
العالم لانه التمييز عندهم وعنا بس هم
دائما التركيز على دول الناميه بالذات
العربيه وهلكونا بهاي القصه تمييز موجود
بكل العالم تمام لكن الفكره
النوع الاجتماعي لازم نحكي بلغه انسان
مراه ورجل ونركز على المتضرر اكثر لكن ما
بنقدر نضلنا نركز على المراه ونعمل ردود
فعل عكسيه عند الرجل هيئه سبب سبب ثاني
انو هم استخدموا نفس الاساليب نفس الطرق
نفس المفاهيم اللي بتناسب مجتمعاتهم ما
عملوا اعتبار نعمل
مفاهيم او اساليب او ادوات تناسب
المجتمعات اللي بنشتغل عليها نحكي بلغتكم
عشان هيك صار في رفض مجتمعي لكل حدا
بيشتغل بحقوق المراه او الجندر لانه هاي
ما غيروها نفس الطريقه ونفس الاسلوب الاهم
من هذا الحكي كله انه
مستحيل نطالب بمساواه بين الجنسين لانه في
فروق بيولوجيه بينهم في فروق سايكولوجيه
في فروق سيولوجيه اذا طلبنا بالمساواه
بينهم نظلمهم الاثنين مع بعض احنا لازم
نطالب
ايه هو هذا يعني هذا موضوع الانسر حيصير
عليه كثير جدا لما الموضوع المساواه
والمساواه حندخل في ملف اخر احنا بنتكلم
عن التمييز العداله زي ما ذكرتي حضرتك
ايوه استاذي ساره تحقق المساواه بطريقه
غير مباشره لما نعمل اعتبار انه في فروق
فرديه بينهم وفي فروق
بشكل عام يعني احنا اصلا انا دائما اقول
احنا ما بندور على المساواه احنا احسن
اصلا في كل الاحوال بس انه
المساواه واللي خلق المشاكل والرفض معاناه
المراه اكثر من ما كانت تعاني اوكي
نتائج عكسيه واضح زي هذه الفكره بس لما
نقول كمان طيب انه زمان كان يقال انه مثلا
كل ما الانسان زاد تعليمه او مثلا بيئته
الاجتماعيه او دخلوا او كذا بيصير متعود
على فكره انه المراه لها حقوق وما الى ذلك
لما يقول لك انه موضوع التمييز حتى ما
بتفرق فيه للطبقه ولا شيء يعني هذا ولا
التعليم ولا الراتب هذا يدل على تراجع
كبير مصيبه يعني
لانه انا دايما بنادي انه ندخل مفهوم
الجندر على الدماغ نعالج الارث الثقافي في
تقبل الاختلاف وتقبل الاخر واننا نتعامل
مع بعض ونتطور مش بس حضاريا وشكليا وعلميا
لازم نتطور فكريا هذا هذا مفهوم الجندر
لازم يعالج الفكر الانساني اولا الجنسين
هذا اللي بيحقق عداله وتقبل هلا تقبل
المراه في بعض المواقع للجيل الحالي صار
افضل واريح لكن لسه الارث الثقافي حاملينه
معهم فراح يضللهم يتعاملوا بلغه تمييزيه
او بلغه اعلى السوبر يعني فوقيه ودنيه مع
بعض تمام فاما الجيل اللي سابق قبل ثلاث
اربع اجيال كان مش معتاد فكان مستهجم لكن
احنا نتغير ونشوف المراه بكل المواقع لكن
نفس الفكر
بنحملهضدها على مستوى
بقول التمكين تمكين الانسان
للجنسين يبدا من العقل بالاول لازم نغربل
هون ولازم نشتغل بلغه ثنائيه لا يمكن نحصل
على عداله حقيقيه وحقوق للمراه بمعزل عن
العمل مع الرجل لازم نشتغل عليهم الاثنين
صح هو كمان التقرير بياكد على هذا الشيء
انه موضوع الاعراف لا زال هو
المهيمن يعني نحن بنشكرك على هذه
التوضيحات كانت معنا من عمان دكتوره عصمت
حوسوا رئيسه مركز الجندر للاستشارات
الاجتماعيه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
يحتفل اليوم بعيد ميلاده ال 77 لكن عيد
ميلاده جاي متزامن مع حدث ما احد بيتمناه
فكما دقائق سيمثل ترامب امام المحكمه
الاتحاديه في ميامي بخصوص 37 تهمه جنائيه
موجهه له بتتعلق باساءه التعامل مع اسرار
حكوميه واحتفاضه بشكل غير قانوني بوثائق
كان نقلها من البيت الابيض من بعد ما
انتهت ولايته في 2021
وبترتبط بشكل اساسي بالامن القومي وكانت
ترامب قال قبلها انه ما عنده اي وثائق قبل
ما يداهموا الامن الفيدرالي العام الماضي
منزله في ويصادر صناديق من الوثائق قالوا
انه من المفترض تكون في الارشيف الوطني
وبيعتبر ترامب اول رئيس امريكي بتوجه له
اتهامات جنائيه المحاكمه ممنوع نقلها
وتصويرها لكن اللي المفروض انه يصير بمجرد
وصول ترامب للمحكمه انه سيوضع رسميا
رهن الاعتقال وبعدين اخذ بصماته الكترونيا
اما بالنسبه للصوره الشهيره اللي خاصه
بالمتهمين هو اسمها المعروفه انه بالمقشط
فمو معروف اذا راح ياخذها او لا او بعدين
مرجح انه يتنازل محاموت رمب عن القراءه
الرسميه لللائحه الاتهامات 37 واللي متوقع
انه قدام القاضي يقول انه بريء منها وقيل
انه متوقع الطلب من القاضي كمان تقييد
اتصالات باي من الشهود لمنع اي عبث محتمل
وبعدها يتوقع الافراج عنه بتعهد شخصي يعني
افراج من دون كفاله ومتوقع بعدها انه يلقي
ترامب خطاب علني امام انصاره في ميامي من
نادي الجولف كل هذه الاتهامات مشاهدينا
بتتزامن مع ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه
القادمه واللي كثير من الناس قالوا انه
ممكن تؤثر على فرصه في العوده الى البيت
الابيض بيتهم بايدن والديمقراطيين بانهم
هم اللي وردتوهم وظلما بكل هذه القصص لمنع
تر مره ثانيه ولكن ترمت ماشي بمبدا يا جبل
ما يهزك ريح واعلن انه ما راح يتنازل عن
الترشح بغض النظر عنه نتيجه معركه
القانونيه من المحاكمه مثل ما قلت لكم
مشاهدينا مو مصوره وممكن حتى دخول ترامب
للمحكمه يكون من كراج تحت الارض يعني ما
راح يتمكن انصاره من انهم يشوفوه مع انهم
بداوا فعليا في التجمع امام المحكمه اللي
شاهد محيطها استنفار امني مكثف واستعدادات
امنيه لتجمع خمسين الف متظاهر وحقيقه كثير
من الناس خايفه من انه ينعاد سيناريو
احداث الكابيتال او انه تصير اعمال شغب
وفوضى
حتى الان في تجمعات لانصار ترامب امام
المحكمه مثل ما قلنا لكن اجدد الصور بتظهر
انه الاعلام والصحفيين امام المحكمه اكثر
بكثير من الانصار حتى الان
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد مستمرين معكم مشاهدينا في
تغطيه تطورات الحادثه المؤسفه لقرش
الغردقه اللي انها حياه الشاب الروسي
فلاديمير بوفوف وعمره 23 سنه امس كنا
تكلمنا عن تقرير وزاره البيئه اللي طلع
وقالت فيه انه القرش هجم على الشاب بدافع
التغذيه وكمان طلع معانا مسؤول في وزاره
البيئه ورد على كل المتداول حول الحادثه
ووضح الحقائق الجديد اليوم انه معهد علوم
البحار قرر البدء بعمليات تحنيط سمكه
القرش من قبل علماء المعهد ليتم وضعها
لاحقا في متحف علوم البحار بالغردقه او
اللي تابع للمعهد نفسه
في المقطع اللي شفتوه بيظهر علماء حول
القرش واحد بيعمل شقوق في جسمها وواحد
ثاني بيفحص الجلد وظاهر كمان في الفيديو
ماده بيضاء في فم القرش واللي بتستخدم في
التحنيطا مشاهدينا انه هذا القرش تم
اصطياده بعد قتله للشاب الروسي وبحسب
السلطات تم استخراج من معدته راس وذراعي
وصدر الشاب اما نصف الثاني في الصيادين
استخرجوا من مياه البحر والروايه بتقول ان
القرش اللي من نوع تايجر كان في طريقه انه
ياكل الشاب كاملا لكن لما بدا يقترب قارب
احد الصيادين ترك نصفه الثاني في الماء
وهرب قبل ما يرجعوا يصيدوا ويقتلوه طيب
عموما ومع تداول فيديو تحنيط القرش كثار
تساءلوا ايش سبب التحنيط واللي راح يعرض
القرش فيه او القرش فيه متحف اصلا في
تفاعلكم احنا تواصلنا مع المعهد القومي
للعلوم والبحار وهذا رد احد الاساتذه فيه
بيتم في المعهد القومي للعلوم البحار
والمصائد
لنشر التوعيه البيئيه بمكونات البيئه
البحريه تمام لكل الاسماك النافقه اللي هي
بتطلع من البحر سواء نافقه نتيجه الحادث
او نافقه طبيعي لا لم تتعفن يعني اي اسماك
نافقه
سواء نافقه طبيعي او نافقه نتيجه لحادث زي
القروش زي الدلافين
بيتم تسليمها
للمعهد القومي للعلوم البحار بمعرفه
المحميات الطبيعيه وشرطه البيئه
وبيتم تحميتها لعرضها على الجمهور فيما
بعد عندنا معروضات موجوده في المتحف
لاسماك قرش ودلافين وعروسه البحر وانواع
محنطات بحريه اخرى من الثلاثينيات ما كانش
في حاجه جايه نتيجه لحادث
قتل انسان كانت حاجات جايه نافقه
وفي حاجات كانت جايه على وشك الموت بسبب
كبر السن وفي حاجات كانت جايه نتيجه لصراع
بين الكادات البحريه مع بعضها
احنا في عمليه التحليط بنزيل كل اللحم
اللي موجود في السمكه والعظم
وبنكتفي بالجلد والفك بس وبيتم ازاله كل
اللحوم عشان ما تتعفنش
وبقايا اللحوم بيتم تجفيفها بالملح بحيث
ان اي رطوبه داخل جلد السمكه بيتم التخلص
منها
وبعدين بيتم
الصبغ اللحم بماده مره اسمها البوركس عشان
عشان الجلد بعد كده ما يسوسش وبعد كده
بيتم حشوها بنشره الخشب
وتتقفل على الشكل الطبيعي بتاع السمك
الاصلي
مستمرين معكم في تفاعلكم كمان في متابعه
القصه المعجزه للنجاه اربعه اطفال
كولومبيين الاطفال اللي تاهوا في غابه
اربعين يوم من بعد ما تحطمت الطائره اللي
كانوا فيها مع والدتهم وقريبهم وماتت
والدتهم والطيار والشخص الثالث وبديهم
الاربعه تايهين في الغابه اربعين يوم
كامله الاخت الكبرى اللي عمرها 13 سنه
ينظر لها انها البطله في القصه فهي حمت
وانتبهت على اخوانها اللي اعمارهم 59 وسنه
واحده فقط وحاليا الاطفال الاربعه في
مستشفى في العاصمه
بسبب طبعا سوء التغذيه والحاله الهزيله
فيها مع انه طبعا معجزه اصلا انهم طلعوا
بلا اصابات حقيقيه من غابات الامازون
الكثيفه اللي مليانه حيوانات خطيره
ومفترسه واللي كمان موطن ملاجئ عصابات
خطيره امس كنا تناولنا تفاصيل كيف كانوا
بياكلوا ايش يشربوا خلال توهانهم في
الغابه وابو طفلين منهم وزوج الست الراحله
قال انه ليزلي قالت انه امهم كانت عايشه
معاهم او ضلت عايشه معاهم اربعه ايام قبل
ما تتوفم وانه هي اللي شجعتهم على النجاه
والنفاذ بجلدهم لكن اليوم في مستجدات
بتغير هذه الروايه تماما فجد الاولاد وابو
امهم اللي توفت نفع هذه القصه اللي قالت
على لسان زوج بنته وقال انه لازمه اخبرتهم
ان الام توفت فورا بعد تحطم الطائره وانه
هي سحبت اختها الرضيعه من بين حطام
الطائره وجثث امها والقتله الثنين وانها
لما شافت جروح اخوانها صارت تشب ملابس
معهم على الطياره وتضمد جراحهم الجد قال
كمان انه بعد اربع ايام جلسوها الاولاد
جنب حطام الطائره بيستنوا قرروا انهم
يبداوا يحاولوا يطلعوا من الغابه ووقتها
بدات تلزلي تترك علامات واثار لهم في كل
مكان على امل انه تلاقيها فرق الانقاذ
وهذا اللي فعلا صار وكان بيطمن الفرق انه
الاولاد
عايشينة كمان قالت للجد انه في مرات فرق
الانقاذ كانت على بعد عشره امتار عنا وعن
اخوتها لكنهم كانوا يستخبوا وتحط يدها على
او تحط يدها على فم اختها الصغيره خوفا
كانت خايفه يكونوا عصابات ويؤذوها هي
واخوانها وكشف الجد كمان الكلام اللي
قالوه الاولاد عن ويلسن كلب الانقاذ
المفقود واللي كان جزء من عمليات البحث
عنهم
عندها
كلب انقاذ استخدم في البحث عن الاولاد
وقالت الفرق انه اختفى هو داخل الغابه
ايام اختفى داخل الغابه ايام ورجع خرج لهم
وبعدها دخل ثاني للغابه ومن يومها ما رجع
الاطفال كشفوا اول مره لقيهم وفضل مرافقهم
ايام وفضل حولهم يعني وبعدها تركهم يبدو
احاول يروح يجيب الانقاذ الاولاد لكن ما
يعرف يوصل لهم ثاني واللافت انه الاولاد
في المستشفى حاليا مو ناسيين ويلسن
وجالسين يرسموه
اجدد المزداول في القصه كمان هي صور
للاطفال الاربعه من المستشفى وهم خلاص
بداوا يتعافوا شويه شويه السلطات قالت
حيبقوا في المستشفى من اسبوع لاسبوعين على
الاقل علشان يتطمنوا على حالتهم تماما
بعدها راح يبقوا مع السلطات في دار رعايه
لغايه الاتفاق على الوصايه عليهم بين زوج
الام الراحله واللي هو ابو اثنين منهم
وبين الجد والجده اللي اتضح انه في خلافات
بينهم وبين زوج بنتهم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم انا عدو
القاكم غدا ان شاء الله في امان الله
[موسيقى]